because you see someone on this side of
the room when we went around talked
about yoga and how the you know the
psychedelic gives the experience on
demand and but are we ready and how do
you gain skills and this sort of thing
to my mind the goal is not the
psychedelic experience the beginning of
the path is the psychedelic experience
so if yoga promises that after 20 years
it will deliver you to the beginning of
the path then you know there's something
seriously wrong here the the psychedelic
sets you at the beginning of the path
and then people do all kinds of things
with it I mean I am amazed I feel there
is more variation in how we deal with
this than in almost any other phase of
human activity because some people seem
to have almost no self respecting and
I've noticed it also touches sexuality
because I don't know how many of you
have ever encountered the place the
Penthouse Forum but this is where people
write in to Penthouse and and detail
these astonishing sexual unpredictable
sexual exploits threesomes foursomes and
12 some that just fell upon them and
whenever I have for some reason some
occasion to read these things
what is amazing to me is that this
appears to be descriptions of the
behavior of an alien species because
there is no self-reflection on what does
this mean you know what does this mean
that I get stuck in an elevator and end
copulating with 12 stockbrokers yes it's
just it's just accepted as how it is
well you get this same thing with
psychedelics where you say to someone
and they say oh yeah and the night in
the 60s I took psychedelics you know wow
it was really strange all these colors
and and voices and and apparently no
self reflection no realization that this
is actually happening to you this is
happening to you therefore the
implications must be fairly central and
then other people immediately get it
they say you know my gosh this plant
this pill shows me that reality is at
least a thousand times larger than I
thought it was showed me that I don't
know who I am
where I am what I am or anything else
and I don't know what it takes to to
instill that in people may be
intellectual self reflection sometimes I
have flashes when I'm giving these talks
of how different it is to be stoned than
to talk about being stoned I mean here
we sit you know in our cotton underwear
just with our where we came from our
schedules in front of us the mundane of
it is so all pervasive and we could be
discussing Gnosticism
more a political action project but
we're discussing instead something
really appalling I think I mean we're
calmly discussing the fact that there is
another world overlapping our own and
very few people will even admit the fact
so I always think and and this is my
symbol of myself to myself I always
think of a wonderful be science fiction
movie I saw when I was a kid where
there's a dinosaur in the swamp and it's
set somewhere in Mexico and the typical
campesino is sent by the patron of the
ranch to gather firewood in the jungle
and he of course encounters this
extremely large rubber reptile roaring
around and then comes back to the ranch
and is pointing back in the woods and is
completely inarticulate trying to say
you know a creature from the it'd a
beast from another dimension is
rampaging around in the forest well they
just dismiss him as you know these
peasants they believe anything you can't
trust them for a moment this is the sort
of situation we're in the
extraterrestrial invasion that so many
people anticipate or the
extra-terrestrial contact that so many
people hope for and that sell so many
cheap newspapers is well underway it's
simply that the words we have to
describe it are utterly inadequate so
words like extraterrestrial invasion
contact with an intelligent species and
of history migration into hyperspace
these are pathetic signifiers of what is
actually happening to
[Music]
[Music]
you